so you said that included in the freedom
of speech is to say things that are
wrong yep
um what is your perspective on hate
speech
hate speech
is the best marketing campaign for
censorship
um and it came from Academia
um of the of the 20th century and that
when I talked about the anti-free speech
movement uh that was one of their first
inventions um there was a lot of talk
about critical race Theory
um and and being against critical race
Theory and fire will sue if you say that
people can't advocate for it or teach it
or research it because you do absolutely
have the right to to pursue it
academically however every time someone
mentions CRT they should also say the
very first project of the people who
founded CRT Richard Delgado Mary metsuda
Etc
was to go was to create this new
category of unprotected speech called
hate speech and to get it banned the
person who enabled this drift of course
was Herbert Marcus in 1965 you know
basically questioning whether or not
free speech should be a sacred value on
the left and he was on the losing side
for a really long time the Liberals you
know the way I grew up that was
basically being pro-free speech was
synonymous with being a liberal but that
started to be
etched away on campus and the way it was
was with with the idea of hate speech um
that essentially oh but you should um we
can designate particularly bad speech as
uh not protected
um and and who's going to enforce it
who's going to decide what hate speech
actually is well it's usually
overwhelmingly can only happen in an
environment of really low Viewpoint
diversity because you have to actually
agree on on what the most hateful and
wrong things are
and there's a Bedrock principle
um it's referred to this in a great case
about flag burning in the first
amendment that I think all the world
could benefit from You Can't Ban speech
just because it's offensive it's too
subjective it basically it's one of the
reasons why the these uh kind of codes
have been more happily adopted in places
like Europe where they have a sense that
there's like a modal German or a modal
Englishman
um and I think this is offensive and
therefore I can say that this is this is
wrong in a more
Multicultural and in a genuinely more
diverse country that's never actually
had an honest thought that there is a
single kind of American there's never
been like we had we had the idea of
Uncle Sam but that was always kind of a
joke
um Boston always knew it wasn't Richmond
always knew it wasn't Georgia always
knew it wasn't you know Alaska like
we've always been a hodgepodge and we
get in a society that diverse that
You Can't Ban things simply because
they're offensive
um and that's that's one of the reasons
why I hate speech is not an unprotected
category of speech and I and I go
further my theory on freedom of speech
is slightly different than most other
constitutional lawyers
um and I think and I think that's
partially because some of the ways some
of these theories although a lot of them
are really good are inadequate they're
not expansive enough and I sometimes
call my theory the pure informational
theory of freedom of speech
um or sometimes when I want to be fancy
the lab and the Looking Glass Theory and
its most important tenant is that there
is that if the goal is the project of
human knowledge which is to know the
world it is you cannot know the world as
it is without knowing what people really
think and what people really think is an
incredibly important fact to know so
every time you're actually saying you
can't say that you're actually depriving
yourself of the knowledge of what people
really think you're causing what Timmer
Quran who's on our Board of advisors
called preference falsification you end
up with an inaccurate picture of the
world which by the way in a lot of cases
um because there are activists who want
to restrict more speech they actually
tend to think that people are more
prejudiced than they uh than they might
be and actually these kind of
restrictions there was a book called
racial paranoia
um that came out in about 15 years ago
that was making the point that the
imposition of some of these codes can
sometimes make people think that the
only thing holding you back from being a
raging racist are these codes so it must
be really really bad it can actually
make all these things worse and one
which we talk about in the book one very
real practical way it makes things worse
is when you censor people it doesn't
change their opinion it just encourages
them to not share it with people who
will get them in trouble so it leads
them to talk to people who they already
agree with and group polarization takes
off so we have some interesting data in
the book
um about how driving people off of
Twitter for example
um you know in 2017 and then again I
think in 2020 driving people to gab led
to you know greater radicalization among
those people it's a very predictable
Force sensorship doesn't actually change
people's minds and it pushes them in
directions that actually by very you
know solid research will actually make
them more radicalized so yeah I think
that the I think that the attempt to ban
hate speech it doesn't really protect us
from it but it gives the government such
a vast uh weapon to use against us that
we will regret giving them
is there ways to sort of to look at
extreme cases to test this idea out a
little bit so if we look on campus yeah
what's your view about allowing say
white supremacists on campus to do to do
speeches okay KKK I think you should be
able to study
what people think and I think it's
important that we actually do so I think
that you know let's take for example Q
Anon
yeah Q anon's wrong
um but where did it come from why did
they think that what's the motivation
who taught them it who came up with
these ideas this is important to
understand history that's under
important to understand modern American
politics and so if you put your act if
you put your scholar hat on and which
you should be curious about kind of
everyone about where they're coming from
Daryl Davis who I'm sure you're familiar
with part of his goal was just simply to
get to know where people were coming
from and in the process he actually
de-radicalized a number of Clans members
when they actually realized that this
black man who would befriended them
actually was compassionate was a decent
person they realized all their
preconceptions were wrong so it can have
a de-radicalizing factor by the way but
even when it doesn't it's still really
important to know what the bad people in
your Society think honestly in some ways
it's for for your own safety it's
probably more important to know what the
bad people in your Society actually
think I personally I don't know
what you think about that but I
personally think that freedom of speech
in cases like that like KKK and campus
can do more harm in the short term
but much more benefit in the long term
because you can sometimes argue for like
this is going to hurt yeah in the short
term but I mean Harvey said this is like
consider the alternative yeah because
you've just kind of made the case for
like this potentially would be a good
thing even in the short term and it
often is I think especially in a stable
Society like ours uh with a strong
middle class all these kinds of things
where people have like the Comforts The
Reason through things yeah
um but you know to me it's like even if
it hurts in the short term even if it
does create more hate in the short term
the freedom of speech has this really
beneficial thing which is it helps you
move towards the truth the entirety of
society towards a deeper more accurate
understanding of life on Earth of
society of how people function of ethics
of metaphysics of everything yeah and
that in the long term is a huge benefit
it gets rid of the Nazis in the long
term even if it adds to the number of
Nazis in the short term yeah well and
meanwhile just for for and the reality
check part of this is people always
bring up what about the clan on campus
I'm like they're never invited
um the the the I haven't seen a case
where they've been invited
um usually this the the clan argument
gets thrown out when people are trying
to excuse and that's why we shouted down
Ben Shapiro right and that's why you
can't have Bill Maher on campus that's
why you know and it's like okay
um you know and it's a it's a little bit
of that what about ISM again about being
like well that thing over there is
terrible and therefore this comedian
shouldn't come